Demography is destiny is a line
you hear often in politics,
and it is a very good yet imperfect guide
to predicting future political outcomes.
The veteran political reporter
Tom Edsall offers a thoughtful
look at some current trends
in the New York Times.
This is striking.
Look at the projected growth
of millennials and younger generations
as a percentage of the electorate
over the next dozen years.
Then consider this millennials,
those between 27 and 42 years old
favorite Democrats
by 14 points in the 2022 midterms.
Gen Z voters those 18 to 26 years old
favorite Democrats
by a whopping 56 points last year.
So demography favors the Democrats
without question.
And that advantage will only grow
unless Republicans
can make significant inroads
but important.
But why hasn't that advantage helped
Democrats more already.
How did Donald Trump win
in 2016
for example
or why did Republicans win the House
last year? Edsel explains it this way.
The white backlash
to growing the growing strength
of liberal constituencies
not only prompted conservative voters
to back Republicans by higher margins,
they also turned out to vote
at exceptionally high rates.
Tom Edsel is here
to join our conversation.
It's great to see you, my old friend.
So explain the backlash.
I will put up one other graphic
as you do,
because it's striking
the younger voters are growing in size.
They're a bigger piece of the voting pie
and they disproportionately
favor Democrats
and yet Republicans
are holding their own.
Here's one reason why.
Look at the evangelical voters
white, white, non-college degree.
Bush versus Trump.
Donald Trump
gets a way higher percentage.
12 points higher among white
without a college degree.
Among white evangelicals,
George W Bush gets 75%.
Donald Trump gets 89%
this is the backlash.
You're talking about populations,
whether it's blue
collar workers or religious voters
who feel somehow threatened.
What's going on? It's true.
Two steps in a sense.
Not only are young voters
voting more for Democrats,
but as they grow older,
they're defying
the basic rule of politics.
That the older
you get, the more conservative
you become.
They're going in the opposite direction
for the first time
over the last three election cycles.
So you see a rise in their democratic
margins and a
rise in the degree that they
turn out
the problem
is this sounds great
for Democrats,
is that white conservatives,
evangelicals, white
Catholics are turning out
way above their numbers.
They're punching more than they are,
harder than they should.
I think the figure is for evangelicals.
Is there
something like 14% of the population now,
but there are 22% of the actual turnout.
That's a huge difference.
But we can show that we show that
in the conversation. White Evangelicals.
48% of the population.
22% of the voters
in 2020 white Catholics.
12% of the population.
16% of the voters in 2020.
It just tells you that you look at
you can look at the pie.
And Democrats, Democratic
leaning voters
are a bigger slice of the pie.
And yet there's always what I call
the push me pull you in demographics
and I mean Dr.
Doolittle not the video game
in the in the sense
that you know
one group starts to pull this way
and another group says
well I feel threatened
and they pull back. Yeah.
I mean that's
the question is it,
Tom, do you feel in looking at
the research
and the data
that it's
for lack of a better way to say it
woke ism, is it because of the what
a lot of these people
see on conservative media about the other
coming in that they're buying into that
or is it all of it?
Well, I think the real fear is that they
they think they're going
to get extinguished
by these
growing numbers
of liberal constituencies.
The best way to turn out
a vote is to get the person scared
The other best way is to get them angry.
And what has happened
is that
leaders on the right
have gotten their voters scared.
And angry.
And the fact is
that they're turning out
in these higher and higher numbers.
Their long term problem is how much juice
can you squeeze out of a lemon
that's actually shrinking.
And over time, it's this this
method of countering the liberal trend
really runs into real problems
as it hits.
This sort of maxes out.
And you just can't
get another drop out of that one right
That's the great point.
If you go back to the original graphic,
we had millennials and younger
generations of majority electorate
by 20, 28.
That that's the point
you're making in the sense
that when you see Donald Trump's attack
today, on birthright
citizenship, when you see the attacks
on transgender Americans,
when you see, you know,
whether it's immigration,
whether it's gay rights, it's
these issues
that you're playing to the base
or our trade, trade
and globalism, globalization.
You're playing a blue collar workers,
you're playing to the evangelical voters.
And yet,
to Tom's point,
how many times when that piece when.
62% of the electorate in 2036
is going to be these younger voters
that song is not going to work anymore
as Bill Clinton said that dog won't hunt
right but but for now
it can't hunt right
I mean we saw
what happened in 2022 with the house
we obviously saw
what happened in 2016 and Donald Trump
is trying to make that dog hunt
in 2024
he is the master of white
grievance politics
the master of white identity politics.
He knows what to say.
He sort of knows
it's having cold words at this point.
It's basically
saying that brown people
are going to come here
and kill you right.
I mean that was during his
you know when he announced his
candidacy in 2016.
I mean that's essentially what he said.
And so they'll play that
over and over again.
You see DeSantis doing the same thing.
The idea
that the woke mob, you know,
is out to get you,
but he's going to be the person
to vanquish it.
So it works,
you know, it's worked
in American politics quite well.
We had
I think Republicans
not want to sort of play
this game of white identity politics,
but Donald Trump played it
and he played it masterfully.
And so part of the challenge
for Republicans,
could somebody break the mold,
if you will?
You do have Nikki Haley,
you have Tim Scott,
you have the big Ramaswamy,
you have Larry Elder.
You do have voters of color, women in the
in the Republican field.
Do they try to practice
a different kind of politics
to bring to widen
the tent, expand the tent,
or do they stay in that way
because Trump proved it can work?
Well,
they have tried,
at least
by emphasizing
their own identities, pointing
to their own personal diversities
to try to bring that
factor to the Republican Party.
But I'm really struck,
especially with the
the growing percentage of younger voters
that are favoring Democrats,
just how little in terms of policy
that Republicans have tried
and reaching out to younger voters.
I think
the closest that you can get
is perhaps
some Republican elected officials
embracing the science of climate change,
saying this is something
that we have to tackle
maybe not in the way
that Democrats are proposing,
but it is certainly a threat
and we have to propose
policies towards it.
But you just kind of step back
and they're not really appealing
to younger voters in the way
with their policy
platforms, with their proposals.
Where do you watch? Where do you watch?
We go back a long way.
Michael Dukakis won West Virginia.
Forget about it now. Right.
Wisconsin, a state where Trump won,
then lost.
Where do you watch for sort of
where's the tipping point in
this demographic tug of war?
Well, I think Wisconsin
is an excellent state.
I actually look at Pennsylvania
as another.
There are a lot of northern Midwestern
purple states
where these tilts are just coming in
and you see what happens is in the states
where they have a higher percentage
of COLLEGE-EDUCATED white voters.
That's where the tipping point occurs.
But and these voters are Democrats,
and that's where the Republicans
really run into big problems
that I urge everyone to pick up.
The New York Times.
It's a long, in-depth article.
It's a lot
it's a lot deeper than we can do
on television.
But, Tom, appreciate your here.